[Música]
les comentaba yo con un viejo filósofo o
rodolfo santander que de los que gracias
a dios todavía viven un viejo filósofo
que escrito muchos libros sobre
heidegger sobre etcétera
un filósofo preocupado
de la situación de esta barahúnda de
redes sociales de esta barahúnda de
disconformidades etcétera y le decía
rodolfo que puerta vez que puerta vez a
esta situación que vivimos y rodolfo me
decía nos hemos olvidado de conversar
nos hemos olvidado de charlar
y en esa misma plática me daba yo cuenta
que te robaba a aquella persona que el
personaje cuando cuando tú hablas con
esos personajes que te roban el espacio
que te que te absorben y te crean una
atmósfera una serie de hilos en los que
tú estás precisamente saboreando lo que
te están diciendo y me acordé de que la
palabra sabiduría la palabra sabiduría
no es solamente de saber la palabra
sabiduría proviene de un latín era de un
término latino sapere que saborear
para ser sabios hay que saborear
y para el saborear necesitas crear un
ambiente un ambiente de conversación
díganme si no es cierto que que a
nosotros nos saca de nuestro entorno
cotidiano no se nos asusta a veces
cuando nuestra pareja cuando alguien
cercano a nosotros con el que convivimos
nos dice tenemos que platicar
porque porque sabemos que tenemos que
platicar el tenemos que conversar va a
generar una atmósfera distinta a la
cotidianidad
y entonces entendí porque rodolfo
santander me dijo nos hemos olvidado de
la de la conversación
qué hace la conversación la conversación
abre silencios
la conversación no es el estar
escupiendo opiniones en una conversación
te abre silencios
que el espacio que les ha pasado a
ustedes en aquellas conversaciones y lo
digo con los más jóvenes pero también
con los que somos más viejos la
maravilla de la conversación silenciosa
con con el enamorado la conversación que
no tiene nada que decir porque te lo
estás diciendo decía che acá cuando tú y
yo nos miramos a los ojos hacemos la
síntesis del mundo
cuántas palabras están insertas en los
silencios de las conversaciones
tengo amigos
y muchos de ellos están por aquí en los
que probablemente nos sentamos en una
mesa
ya no nos dejan fumar pero bueno yo me
echo un cigarrito y con una y con una
copa de vino no haces más que estar
tomando una copa de vino y charlando sin
palabras porque porque permite hacer esa
síntesis de la charla sin palabras de la
conversación sin palabras y es la que de
pronto creo yo que nos va a permitir el
tema de nuestro de nuestro usted es la
transformación y ahí quiero llegar ahora
a dónde puede llegar la charla a dónde
puede llegar la conversación saben como
le llamaba
a las charlas
honorato de balzac honoré de balzac la
llamaba el verdadero parlamento del
pueblo balsa llamaba a la gente que se
reunía la llamaba el verdadero
parlamento del pueblo porque es en las
charlas donde verdaderamente sale la
verdad donde salen los sentimientos los
pensamientos reales cuántos de nosotros
amigos cuántos de nosotros hemos tomado
decisiones trascendentales
hemos decidido estudiar esto hemos
decidido tomar un rumbo hemos decidido
tomar la militancia tomar la decisión de
predicar de transformar a partir de una
charla a partir de una conversación en
la que se te ha despertado aquello que
estaba dormido por eso baltar llamaba a
las charlas el parlamento verdadero del
pueblo
en méxico en méxico surgió
una escuela bueno muchos de ustedes
saben que en parís hubo los cafés de
parís verdad
donde se gestó donde se gestan los
pensamientos de voltaire etcétera y era
el café es que se hacían en parís pero
que afecta a los que se reunían a ésta a
tomar café ya charlar a conversar en
méxico surgió lo que fue el ateneo de la
juventud con filósofos como antonio caso
alfonso reyes y cuando uno habla y se
los digo particularmente a mis amigos
jóvenes que están aquí cuando uno habla
de esos personajes se imaginaron a unos
viajes y llosa y chochos malhumorado se
hablan no eran jóvenes jóvenes inquietos
que querían también cambiar las cosas
que después fueron filósofos pero que en
ese momento comenzaron a reunirse para
conversar fíjate lo que es la
trascendencia de la conversación
por qué porque es importante la
conversación porque porque nos descubre
con responsabilidad porque la
conversación verdadera nos arranca de
nuestra soledad de egoísta
nuestra soledad de egoísta a la que
bauman ha llamado
en la mejor mercancía la soledad para
poderse explotar en una infinidad de
asuntos como pudieran ser
en ciertos casos las redes no no no y tú
pero las redes son maravillosas personas
herramientas previas no sustituyen a la
conversación
la diferencia entre teclear y conversar
tiene una palabra
me pongo a juicio de alguien que quiero
mucho que está aquí el padre jesús
la diferencia entre teclear y conversar
es la compasión
en la charla con padeces padeces con el
otro
esa es la compasión cuidado la compasión
es la lástima la lástima no sirve para
nada la lástima es estéril la compasión
es padecer con el otro y sólo en la
charla y en la cercanía humana padeces
con el otro con padeces esa es la
diferencia de crear
en el tecleo la compasión está un poco
hecho a un lado en el tecleo estoy yo en
el teclado soy protagonista en el tecleo
sentenció dictaminó en la charla en la
conversación las palabras son
maravillosas conversas
se vierten en un espacio común distintas
maneras de ver la vida
por eso conversas por eso pones en común
comunicas
qué pasa cuando no hay conversación
cuando no hay conversación se van a
imponer entonces las dictaduras las
dictaduras de la palabra
se jerarquiza lo irracional se sentencia
se miente se falsea
y es un mundo me lo van a decir ustedes
o no donde lo que nos está comiendo es
la jerarquía de lo irracional la
jerarquía del visceral ismo la jerarquía
del mero sentimiento charlemos
conversemos
generemos esos espacios
tenía tres puntos charlar no es escupir
opiniones inconexas charlas no es
destrozar al otro charlar no es cumplir
los parámetros del mercado charlando
sentarse a ver si tienes el último
modelo del teléfono
inteligente charlar no es ver la moda a
nivel lo que el otro servicio si es muy
rico el chisme yo es muy bonito
comercial a gente
pero eso no es conversar la conversación
tiene otros elementos
yo quisiera
y me gustaría y mis amigos a quienes
quiero tanto que están aquí al rector
que lo saben muchos años han sido la
esperanza de cambiar las estructuras en
la enseñanza si nuestros salones de
clase fueran espacios de conversaciones
de charla nos exigiríamos más si
nuestros espacios
académicos fueran de charla creceríamos
estuvo el ateneo pero en espacios
abiertos filósofos como ortega y gasset
se formaron en un espacio que se llamaba
la escuela libre de enseñanza en españa
y saben donde estudiaban en los cafés de
españa' en las playas
conversábamos teníamos el compromiso de
nuestra soledad personal para
compartirla con los demás
yo les puedo asegurar
y aquí estarán ustedes lo que les decía
hace un momento que en los espacios de
charla se han generado decisiones
personales de cada uno se han generado
espacios de inclusión y en las
conversaciones hemos asumido que tenemos
un compromiso con un mundo olvidado
en la conversación nos damos cuenta
que abandonamos
lo que ignacio llamaba
nuestra falsa inocencia
nosotros nos sentimos inocentes
las cosas están mal pero yo estoy bien
en la charla abandonase esa falsa
inocencia en la charla sabes que eres
corresponsable de ese mundo olvidado en
la charla sabes que no puedes desde el
nicho de tu comodidad criticar lo que
está sucediendo porque tú formas parte
de aquello
pero saben qué
la charla es un arte
y este es un tema aparte pero a mí me
gustaría que dijeron que es el arte
acabamos de tener la participación de un
artista y me no me dejará mentir cuando
sabes que algo es arte
cuando aquello que tienes enfrente
cuando después de contemplar aquel
aquello que tienes enfrente tú te has
transformado
cuando después de ver una pieza de
ballet cuando después de contemplar una
escultura cuando después de leer un
libro no eres el mismo
ahí es donde entiendes el arte por eso
hay que tener mucho cuidado con el falso
arte que de pronto prolifera por ahí
porque no hace más que reproducir
emociones reproducir aspectos triviales
que finalmente me permiten entrar y
salir sin ninguna transformación bueno
la charla es un arte
la charla es un arte porque te permite
te permite transformarte
decía yo
que la charla nos presenta un mundo
olvidado
nos arranca de nuestra normalización de
nuestra falsa inocencia nos
corresponsabiliza
cuando nos acercamos
al arte de conversar transformamos
azul hace un momento el compañero
artista decía yo estoy seguro que a
partir de esa conversación con su
sobrinito esa fue una conversación esa
es la que te da el chispazo para salir
adelante
en una conversación te das cuenta de la
edad que tienes
este servidor decía no sé no se
desilusionen los que tienen 24 años
hombre muchas gracias yo decidí estudiar
un doctorado en los 55
porque porque tienes la posibilidad de
conversar de ver al otro de saber que
alguien te necesita y que tú eres
necesitado por los demás esta es mi
invitación
no desprestigio los chats no
desprestigio el tecleo
pero el tecleo solitario el tecleo que
me hace protagonista de la historia lo
que va generando es violencia lo que va
generando desconfianza ción fíjense la
diferencia que hay entre la palabra
conversación con front acción vale mucho
la pena detenerse en nuestras palabras
nuestro español es maravilloso
confrontas enfrentas con el otro
conversas viertes en el otro
la invitación en este espacio
es a conversar
conversemos abramos espacios de
conversación abramos espacios artísticos
de la conversación
el arte es conversación
y nosotros estamos llamados creo yo si
queremos transformar a conversar
no lo echemos al olvido y repito las
palabras de rodolfo santander cual es
esperanza nos hemos olvidado de
conversar esa es mi invitación muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]